okay so a speaker is came in shank and
we talked about holiness amplification
this test okay I'm good okay um well I
mean actually I want to first tell you
about a title but I think I just been
called Chi Minh tomb which is not really
me so if I means that I caused her
sitting in the audience and he is just
to computer science to be really you
know show my slides so so I'm prison
here so I'm Michele D will find in your
ceragon so our work is about the general
runnin runnin simplification with
nonstick only security so if you have
trouble understanding the keyword in the
title that's totally fine that means you
have something ah I mean not this kind
of saying but I don't know okay so you
have you I had something to take home so
this John and work with young she and
Nick I mean so Connie may help and you
just answer your question if I fail to
do that so I think the last talk is a
bit overwhelming they let me just show
something you know maybe just like a
happy story and you can get something so
so let me just pretend to be a serious
error I go visit us and like you know
what jumper skilled as you know this
good time for quantum information series
to jump into the black hole and this is
like the top picture a gallant by
googling that you see this is like a
light go picture for the gradient of a
tube backhoe and I just held on that
sort I still want to work on some saying
you know starting fundamental physics
question that maybe that's more
accessible for for us for you know as a
computer scientist so this is it too
much I think you know so this talks is
really about one problem you know we can
do as a comparison test and something
you know about a fundamental physics so
what's about so it's about the redness
or a no it's like it may be even more
fundamental question or philosophic
question is our word deterministic or
how cute fundamentally I'm particularly
events been possible
and a certifiable so well I mean just
showing the the per semester good pass
side of this question we can out be sure
without believing of its existence so it
could be the case that we're like you
know that people start living in the
movie matrix at some battery from the
machine we're leaving in all ways just
to control by some machine where you
know some you know total deterministic
mechanics running behind everything we
cannot rule out that possibility but you
know somehow if you believe that that's
the end of the talk that way trying to
be a more opportunity so let's think
what if you know there's some
possibility that it's not this case so
what I can do so maybe you can think
about something like if the word is
either deterministic or maybe it's now
the trick what I can say about it so
here's our question so that's
non-deterministic Ward imply a truly
random word so you see there's a gap you
know the gap is there too even though
the word is not you know deterministic
that that's not me you can have like
perfect running events exist in your
world so so whatever you know we're
asking actually this the first asked by
callback render it should see the
possibility of establishing a dichotomy
theorem and what in order to do that so
this is a very high level picture so
assume you have some oh I don't see my
point okay so you have some a little bit
of non deterministic same so which I
just roughly call the week uncertainty
in for now but we see you know the
mathematic structure of that later so we
want to have some kind of procedure to
amplify this week uncertainty to full
uncertainty which means uniform bits or
uniform events but doing that we don't
want to introduce any actor randomness
so if we can achieve such a sane then we
can achieve some economies there and
basically says either the ward is
deterministic or we can fully create a
uniform random event
so this is a watch you know this talk is
really about this is the question we
want to do of course you know this is
always the easy part and we want you
leaving that you know slightly harder
part we are assumed you know working on
the the case where the word is now
deterministic okay and you see this is a
really you know very fundamental physics
person and even in a philosophical
question and indeed that's why this you
know the program was proposed by
physicist by call back trainer in 2012
you know the answer the question can we
certify the existence so for to
reminisce based on physical oars and I'd
ittle bit in terms of computer science
so what this is really asking is that
can we generate uniform bits from week
source and we want to endure minimal
assumptions ok so just let me be more
specific about this question and by
introducing you know in a models you
just really talk about it since more
concretely so we imagine we have some
system no that's the system or you can
imagine you know some experiments or
whatever it is 12 generate a one a
single bit ok a single bit out and you
do have the you know observer which I
basically that that's the rest of the
word and we want you of course just you
see whether it's possible then this
particular bit be will be like in you
know uniform bits in the eye of these
observer you and of course as I just
mentioned you you don't want to leave in
a determinist award where you don't have
anything to be Rendon so there's a first
necessary assumption for this to help is
that you need to have a weak source or
some uncertainty to start with but how
you know but just by formulating in this
way you immediately there should be
another necessary on sumption so what's
that has necessary sumption which is
kind of triggers that you can now this
line the system to basic is singularly
beat you so the system need to keep this
be I mean without entertaining
it is and we do have a term especially
when people started the foundation for
quantum mechanics or even you know
foundation of any physics theorem that's
called nonstick donating condition so we
want you to hell the between system and
it so basically we show there to
necessary assumption you know you know
that you make this happen okay so let me
just to show you some you know maybe you
have already thinking about this
question you have some solutions so let
me just tell you some semi working
solutions but actually the requiring
additional assumptions so first let's
assume your system is totally classical
and this actually has been a
well-studied question in the topic our
retinas extraction and there I want you
just you know ignore a many technical
detail but the casings that you always
need to have independent week source
that means you you don't have you cannot
just have why makes you have more and
you need to have independence assumption
between them in order for you to do
anything like this okay and of course
you know this is qi p why you're using
classical system so how about quantum
system and we do have something cut you
know kuantan retinues random number
generator trains already commercialize
the product and if you look into the
mathematics of quantum mechanics you see
this is like intrinsically rendon in a
staff so why can't you just get it out
of this random bitten by just you know
using quantum mechanics or quantum
devices so there's the first level
question about this and this is more
like a practical level of saying then is
this you know how can you be sure you
know this device especially the device
in your particular experiment that's
exactly what you want or it does exactly
what is in a minute to be so we
basically assume you know this is
correct you know it does everything we
want so it can be sure is you know some
random bits so we have the additional
assumption like you know we assume the
Quran yourself the quantity y
if we don't want to assume that so the
other Church alternative ways that we
need to perform some certifications and
sins so that's like the first layer of
question so if there's even more
fundamental issue if we you know once
you take this approach so that's the
running is you know the chili just come
from assuming quantum mechanics well if
we use in and believe the quantum
mechanics explain the inner working of
the nature well that's the case you can
possibly see you know this is you know
randon and in that case we basically
drew out the determines ward you know we
don't need to start to think about the
question from the very beginning if we
want to keep the assumption that you
know or the possibility that we could
live in a determinist award so that
means quantum mechanics can be
incomplete so they could be eternity of
determine serie explain what we have
seen so far and it's consistent with the
prediction of a quantum mechanics then
in that case we can still not a rule you
know conclude this is random but just as
you know believe in quantum mechanics
and is the mathematics behind it okay so
so here's the question you know we have
seen you know something close to what we
want but we don't want to assume you
know quantum mechanics explain the
nature and we don't want to trust all
the devices you know we're using can we
still generate a uniform base from week
sources so that's the question we really
want to do for in this talk okay and if
you just just stare at this worse I mean
if you I mean have been working on a
little bit in you know between this
session maybe no where's about
device-independent cryptography so maybe
this rings a bell so this is basically
this is exactly what we meant to do in
the device independent cryptography so
this limey elaborate a little bit on
that so in you know the device
independent core java free basically
says we don't want you trust the inner
working of any devices due to either
technique or maybe even more fundamental
issues
but still we want to leverage those
machines their quantum machines and we
are human beings we can only use
kinetica operations so that's what
device independent quantum cryptography
does and how this is possible as you
know classical human being to do that so
this is a you know the key tool were
using we use an eval test to detect the
Nano ecology in quantum system and we
force them to be kuantan or maybe even
first them to you know just goes away
from the classical region and by using
that you know we can achieve a lot of
lot of sins and this is a you know
incomplete list of all the successful
examples and if you hear you see the
other is talk they can be sought as
special cases in the device independent
you know star d and we're going to have
one a thing right app that's the planner
talk about you know diversity vendor q
KD okay so basically this will be the
framework we're using to solve our
problem so just let's get back to our
problem so this is a code back to render
2012 paper and they say they want you
certify to running is from no way
crendon is and they want to adapt the
device independent framework and by
using the bail violation to do that and
they gave a name this is called
readiness amplification so we we've seen
there to necessary assumption as you
know in the beginning of this talk I say
you need to have some assumption on this
in a week source or some uncertainty and
the other assumptions that you want to
have not signaling you know condition so
so here's the way that the code back
trainer models the first one so what do
you know do we mean by week stores so
the proposal of cobourg Reiner's to
basically say week source is equivalent
to set about the running source and the
mathematically is says it's just you
know am bit string don't see my pointer
but so it's envious string and if you
look at every single bit
condition on the you know any possible
you know fixing number of bits of all
the first one is still have some
uncertainty so if you look at this in
ecology epsilon 0 then the next vision
will be perfectly uniform and Absalom is
large then it's become more biased and
the reason why we you know seeing this
is a good modeling of the week source I
think their physical principle behind
choosing this one and this is a
beautiful argument in the original paper
by call back your inner which I probably
don't have time to go into details right
now and what they can do so they can use
you know the framework I just mentioned
you know moduli some technical condition
that they can amplify for any epsilon s
resource we're absolutely you know very
small number here it's like it's close
to be uniform but it's not perfect
uniform and they can distill one uniform
based out of it and here's the roughly
the movie know the protocol so so
basically which we have the eve which is
you know just model as the the rest of
the world and he has the device in a and
B which is you know we don't trust we
only see the classical you know input
output of the device and you know the
most important since that loss devices
they don't commute so we have some you
know not signal condition you know
position on that and a does have some
has resource so you know you know share
I have some way to choose the input from
the S resource you know gets output and
to see whether this pass some tests or
not and if a passage has and we choose
steel furnace resource you know select
what's the output of the final vertical
and you know what you Eva destiny she
gets the output of vitis if even can
ouch you know by using like you know
putting some operations on her side and
observing outputs you guess Alice's
autocorrect late then you know this
article output an SS Alfred well be look
uniform to eat
so that's roughly you know what's the
code box rain is perfect or dads and
achieve this for you know absolute s
resource so just let's go back to put
this particular bacteria into our
contacts talking about a dichotomous
earn so we want to have that concert and
say either deterministic or it can be
certified certifiable random so here we
have you know s3 source model as the
week renan is and you can have wages
should certify it should be in a one
uniform bit by using code box trainers
protocol and of course remember you know
here we are moduli cell you know i just
don't go each many technical condition
but you see if we can weaker in all the
assumptions on this procedure then we
get stronger that common in steering so
another dimension which i didn't mention
that this also requires that we wanted
non-secure insecurity you know we have
already talked about the assumption on
the week source so what's the nonstick
you learn security so so roughly
speaking basically you can allow your
even have any non-secured correlations
with you know all the devices and still
you want the output is you know it's a
uniform to the other versuri so the
reason why now signals to our security
is stronger is because just taking CH sh
for example if you share now second
strategy you can win this you know given
perfectly but if you only have a quantum
power you cannot win this perfectly so
potentially not signal security well in
a provider you know powell even in a
more powerful anniversary to guess about
a bit so this process a stronger you
know requirement on a security so as I
said go back trainer you know it's the
first result on this topic and we do see
a lot of development of all this you
know running amplification protocols
where the improved bo-zone you know the
absolute for all the s3 source and also
improve the security to pronounce
signaling and there adds a dimension
site which I don't you know put it on
the table like you know I you know
whether the in this particular robust
you sound like illness noise in the
implementation or maybe you know if you
consider how many boxes you need to use
okay so that's all the positive you know
Rosanna we got from the development of
randomness amplification protocols and
they're all good there a lot of you know
techniques developed you know in this
development and I didn't really talk
about this part of the story the you
know the the right column because that's
the part you know we are in our research
is really about and we have some you
know I think it's like we found some
saying that we would like to improve on
all existing run exemplification
protocol and the part we want to improve
on is about the source so this recalls
so all the priests ones writing
simplification protocol they always
assume there's three source as your
input and the first day as a you know
computer scientist oh you know just you
know get way way about a physical
intuition we suggest as resources still
very strong assumption it guarantees
entropy for every single bit now if we
want to go back into the the physical
argument a bike over trainer to see why
they model are the weak sources resource
you know they can you know this is can
still be questionable although I'm not
sure whether you know I'm the right
person to do that but you see the
required as we bid to be a lucky BTW
level so for every new bit it needs to
be have some uncertainty condition all
the purse bit so it could be the case
you still have s restructure but it's
like a block of ice you don't have you
know that strong you know that's you
know conditional every single
cert is that for all the following
development you know in order to achieve
better parameters or you know reduced
number of boxes or achieve like
robustness in the noise and they always
require some additional assumption about
like the the relation between the source
and device or the source and the
adversary you know the required some
kind of independence so of course I
think some of it can you know this
condition can be justified if you
believe in more principle in physics or
someone can be justified if you sing you
know that's the way we can do it the
experiments that you know it's just a
proof of principle or you know you know
I said peers you know serious story can
we reduce all these assumptions on the
source to the minimum to the only source
and assumption we really require we
don't want to have any more assumptions
other than necessary and then basically
this is what we want to do and then this
is what different hour is out front all
the professor is out so in order to do
that we want to first know what you know
doing me by like a minimal condition on
the source so this just kills the back
to our you know the first principle
question we want you to achieve with the
economy syrup so so basically we want to
ask what's the minimum week source in a
non deterministic or and so our you know
proposal is the mineral resource and if
you do have this condition of the
definition for me entropy source in the
classical words basically says it's the
minus log of the maximum probability of
getting that and if its search you know
it's something deterministic you have
perfect you know probability gets in
that and that's zero and you know this
can be easily extended if you have like
a non singular and correlation you still
define it in the operational way you
want to ask what's the the log of the
mind you know the minus log of the
maximum probability of kids in that
source and so just as in a side note
this is a this is a general major of the
running this and actually is something
we are defined in the classical
literature of a redness extraction the
capture the amount of a uniform bills
can be
extracted you know using classical mins
and the more importantly for us and for
the dichotomy theorem is that if the
word is non-deterministic that means
there's tribute some uncertainty and
you're guessing probably won't be one
and if you use this kind F inition so
that means you have a nonzero me on TV
and that's almost you know as the
minimal assumption we can achieve so
that's why we want to use this you know
notion to model the week source and by
using this kind of notion so we so what
we have achieved in this also talking qi
p 2014 is that we are using the notion
of a million tribute source and we can
you know do the running simplification
and we don't assume anything you know on
the source relation with the device and
the anniversary other than it has some
kind of me entropy and we can do that
you know achieving the content security
where we assume you know the adversary's
sharing some you know content
correlation with the devices and what we
you know you know half in this year crap
is that basically we improve this
content to non signaling so in a one
language a one-line message for this
talk is there do we have the readiness
of the vacation protocol for any me
entrepreneurs achieving nonstick and
only security and we don't ask them any
other assumption than that and if i can
give you something more specific so this
is like on a technical level what we
have so we assume your source has little
villains you know me entropy condition
the device not even conditioned
anniversary and we assume the event in
the anniversary and the device sharon on
signal condition so we don't assume
anything else so to basically oh so what
we get can give you a what we call the
idea that concern where you mode of the
week source by just a me entropy and we
you know technically what to achieve is
even more than that because we only
require you have some metra peak if
only look at the local system of the
source and device you don't even look at
the anniversary system so it's like a
local certainty can imply global you
know certifiable global randomness so
that's our result so do we have any
questions so far ok so I'm I'll give you
a you know just brief high-level review
of how we achieve this in the rest of
the top so um so when talking about our
constructions and I think it's good to
see what happened out for out all the
rest of the top you know the particulars
we've seen the renderings amplification
so this is like typical one your get sv
soars you just use the S we source
directly put into device and you designs
very you know sometimes sophistic m's
and make us three structures and II hope
you oughta put is good now usually that
takes a lot you know and effort in
analyzing those games and we do know how
to handle you know instructors me and
tribute source by using that so so what
we have them is that we borrow some
ideas from you know computer science
story or more specifically i think the
ideas in crypto so we won't you um you
know instead of directly using the input
tube fitting all the devices we do
something like a classical
pre-processing and we want you you know
somehow massage the the source such that
we have some nice property and that's
Barbara here is that we want to have
something is called somewhere randomness
which I know just go talk a little bit
more and in the second step because it's
just the sum runnin is there should be
some correlations their mountain las
vacas we want to have some which
Decapolis correlations and there's a
technical ago we launched unsure and
basically want to achieve is that in
order to decouple those correlations we
need to have some quantum protocol when
your input is
lighted but this output it can be
totally decomposed and we can be sure
you know they're such a nosy I exist
among all its blocks and you basically
using the XOR to pick the right one you
don't know which one is good better you
can use XR to pick the right one okay so
so this is basically the same exactly
the same framework we use for our you
know Qi peaches on the 14 talk is about
a Qantas security and if you're happy
with this and you can easily see what we
need to do is basically extend this to
the non signal security and that's
exactly what we have done and you know
unfortunately it's not really that
simple as you know you might thought or
maybe we might ought we took a lot of
energy or you know efforts just to
extend to the now signaling a setting
and here i can actually share some of
the I think conceptual difficulty that
we encounter then maybe also generic to
either you know not signaling security
are you know maybe proofing the device
dependent setting so but but like I said
you know what you want to do you
basically just want to you know extend
the national security for each step and
we want to have a you know somewhere
near announced tickling source and we
want you to the decoupling and we use
something called it quits tonight in the
content setting and we are showing this
you know we don't believe in the housing
the not signal sitting and we have way
around the edge and also a show you know
there's some difficulty to just talking
about how you can control errors in the
composition when you're dealing with a
nonstick you learning system so I'll see
how much I can cover maybe not too much
but let me just go through them so the
first part is the summary readiness it's
a it's just a block of you knows string
and we know if you look at some block
its marginal well be uniform so which
achieved this you know callin security
using a quantum proof strong extractor
so some object you can just assume is to
give you the nice construction like this
basically we've if we have any attribute
source in and we just enumerate all the
seat we generate each output and you
know put them together we know the sun
block will be uniform and what we can
conclude even stronger we can use it a
process in to show that block is uniform
even to all the possible devices if we
start with some major resource has
entropy to the device so so actually
this kind of argument totally breaks
down if we move it to denounce ignorance
it in and why is that so first if you
look into our paper we show if we want
to extend a quantum proof extractor to
the non second improving structure
that's hopeless because such sin does
not exist and we have a strong counter
example to show you and this does not
exist even for extracting a single bit
and maybe this requirement to you know
have the one you know block to be
uniform to all devices that's also
stronger you know the match is stronger
requirement should have in the non
signal setting so so basically you know
what do i do you know we change our
problem we basically you know this is
now this is a very strong requirement
not necessary for our construction to go
through so instead of in asking you know
for I the block to be uniform to all
devices I just need to ask for this
block for some devices well if you you
know reduce is the requirement then you
can hope for something good and indeed
we can achieve this kind of go but we
need to pay and then we need to pay a
lot a lot a in the sense that can still
be we can still up for that so well I
mean night I won't choose I won't show
you how you can prove that a so
this also explains why you know or give
you a hint that why our not signaling
protocol has been a way more boxes than
the quantum one so I mean okay so so
this limey goes to
the second point quickly so we mentioned
there's a Coon's limousine for our
quantum security proof and we don't know
how to do that for an unsecured in case
and the way of doing that it's just this
week go back to see you know what not
signaling protocol we can directly make
use of so by doing that you know we have
a one good candidate and so what we have
done is because we now have a much
better input to that protocol other than
this sense of either running towards the
starways so we can moduli simplify their
proof and we can make it a robust and we
can serve this one dimension if you're
really looking through that paper so the
original one the the only show there
exists a given function to get the final
output and a week we can show you can
that can be efficiently generated so let
me just quickly skip that okay so the
last the same which is I think this is
some may be very generic sane so in
order to you know handle the final
composition so we all were simply find
saying you have uniform state adjust our
ways for the analysis but actually what
you have is something close to uniform
so you see this tiny arrow maybe not a
really you know a big deal in the
content setting and so the the abstract
problem we really need to deal with is
just imagine you have some local system
and you have you know global system like
this if you have you know another
imaginary system in the idea war that's
close to the the local system in the
real world can we find also you know
gute global system in the ID awards such
that the loads to global system they're
close by and we do know how to do that
for the quantum sitting and make use of
a lot of quantum structure and we we
actually believe that you know such
generic you know solution is not
possible in the now secure and sitting
and so ternity we need to
basically repeat NSS wees the you know
the close to uniform city in mine so so
basically so this is the one p Chloe we
found a identify from the previous
analysis so what we do is in a basic
back contradiction if this does not hold
we want to construct something I've had
distinguisher so this idea from Krypto
and we prove a contradiction by doing
that so I if there's one thing I really
want to highlight I think although I'm
probably have time to tell you the
details is that this is a not you know
very traditional poverty it's a it's a
poverty of this virtual yourself and
your acting about the probability of
that property to happen it's very
involved in you see this just by looking
at the definition of itself and this you
know that's I think in the most
ticketing departing our paper okay so
maybe just let me summarize what we have
shown so we have shown a runnings
amplification protocol under the minimal
assumption basically we reduce the
assumption all the source and it just
needs to be a local uncertainty well
imply 35 of global uniform randomness so
that's the way we achieve our in what we
call the idea that condom in serum and
if you hear a little bit about the
parameter we have we need like a poly
one over epsilon me entropy source to
Starbase if you want to certify have
some calls to uniform bits and we do
have a do need to use a lot of devices
and we also think we probably have
introduced some genetic tools for to do
is not signaling system and I think
obviously open question will be you know
improve our analysis you know maybe you
know we're just really pessimistic about
our tool or maybe you know improve our
construction I think in the missing to
reduce number of boxes and hopefully you
know such thinking found applications in
other you know not secondly staff like
and maybe we want to show now seeking
security for di q KD or maybe for the
rnase expansion or maybe even something
when I can not see any information
theory and I thank you you and now and
hopefully I can get some question before
jumping through the black hole thank you
[Applause]
questions
how much mean entropy do you need source
yeah I mean we have shows like four if
we want to study von one bit epsilon
closure uniform you need like a party
one or rap song if you're asking like
what's the party I don't really recall
it is that expression it's the fraction
I mean your source has n bits and I
guess you need a fraction of min entropy
I mean right so if you're weak source
you start with has n bits how much mean
entropy do you need from these n bits
what is the fraction of me entropy or
wow or it can be arbitrarily small I
think it can be absurd right I mean
maybe my culture can help with that
question yes
right hi hi there's two systems i'm
familiar with reduced entropy random
number sources one is where you have a
bias so for example you get a bit string
it's eighty percent zero bits and only
twenty percent one bits and the other
kind exhibits internal correlation so if
you get bits they tend to be self
correlated like 0 0 0 0 mmm 1 111 00 and
in that in those cases if you run a
standard test like die or die hard
against those random number sources
it'll indicate a randomness factor of
point2 or something like that mm-hmm
does this method give you similar
numeric output as to the quality of the
randomness I so I what I believe is that
you know what you're saying is like more
like such as do test for testing how
much readiness is inside a source so
what we more you know care about is
about likes erotica you know guarantee
for you know follow this guy
mathematical definition and um I I don't
think it's quite a comparable um I'm
seeing well will the underlying lack of
randomness leak through into your
reported numbers why mean I I don't
quite see directives through our
construction that
so in some sense I think we we can we
can treat you know you can't reach out
where protocol is some kind of you know
more sophisticated that there you also
need to make use of some quantum devices
you know it will help you do that test
and i think there's also one distinction
from what your set and watch this is
really about so what you said the run is
coming from the source itself so you say
we have a source coming in and we do
some tests you know if the renin is the
soil in a drain is it coming from the
source but what we have shows here the
readiness or in what abilities truly
coming from the devices the quantum
devices or the non singular devices so
all this input may attribute source is
the best teacher helped us to certify
whether the device is really you know
doing their job so i think that our
engine of the running is somehow
different but you know if we if you
allow such a kind of Newt you know
mechanics adding to the testing Rendon
is you know I think this just a more
generalized way of certifying readiness
so that's also why we call this
certification of readiness yeah okay
thank you see if down no more questions
let's sync here d and all this because
again
[Applause]